This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.|||这是一个 I-Heart 播客。品质保证。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《以防万一》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯。这个空间专门探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在任何其他地方都觉得不太安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是在跟一位经验丰富的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着一套隐形的盔甲。它向世界传递出一个信号：你可不好惹。但这并不意味着只要你有这个能力，就必须这样做，来听听
the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier,
the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier,|||iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或其他你获取播客的平台，以艰难的方式汲取教训。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些磨难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、
more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.|||更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。也就是在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 TWO%。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个惯犯骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello, everyone. I am fresh out of the office ready to record this episode for you. It's a pretty personal one. It's a deep one. It's a vulnerable one. That's what we always try and do. on this podcast, something that I haven't really talked about before. We're going to talk about antidepressants. Yeah, you've clicked on this.
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello, everyone. I am fresh out of the office ready to record this episode for you. It's a pretty personal one. It's a deep one. It's a vulnerable one. That's what we always try and do. on this podcast, something that I haven't really talked about before. We're going to talk about antidepressants. Yeah, you've clicked on this.|||听闺蜜的话。相信我，宝贝，在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或任何你收听播客的地方。欢迎回到《20多岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们探讨20多岁时的一些重大生活变化和转变，以及它们对我们心理的意义。大家好。我刚下班，准备为你们录制这一期节目。这是一个相当个人化的主题。这是一个深刻的主题。这是一个展现脆弱的主题。这也是我们在这档播客中一直努力去做的，谈论一些我以前没有真诚聊过的事情。我们要聊的是抗抑郁药。是的，既然你点进来了，
You know what you're in for. Or maybe you don't. So I'll give you a little overview of kind of why I wanted to talk about this, what we're going to talk about, what it involves, and hopefully answer some questions about what it's like from my personal experience, taking antidepressants, why people take them, where it fits in with this broader decade. the subject of this podcast.
You know what you're in for. Or maybe you don't. So I'll give you a little overview of kind of why I wanted to talk about this, what we're going to talk about, what it involves, and hopefully answer some questions about what it's like from my personal experience, taking antidepressants, why people take them, where it fits in with this broader decade. the subject of this podcast.|||你就知道你要面对的是什么。或者你可能还不知道。所以我先简单概述一下我为什么想聊这个，我们要聊些什么，它涉及哪些内容，并希望能解答一些关于我个人服用抗抑郁药的经历是怎样的、人们为什么要服用抗抑郁药，以及它如何契合我们这个人生阶段的问题。
So I think that the topic of antidepressants is super interesting, but also super misunderstood by a lot of people. And it goes without saying, I'm a little bit nervous to record this. It's quite a vulnerable topic, I think, as much as our society has gotten to the point of kind of downgrading, some stigma around common mental illnesses like depression and anxiety, there still is, I think, a big corner of society that sees people who experience mental illness as weak or incapable, unable to kind of operate in society. I just think that's bullshit, firstly. But I also kind of want
So I think that the topic of antidepressants is super interesting, but also super misunderstood by a lot of people. And it goes without saying, I'm a little bit nervous to record this. It's quite a vulnerable topic, I think, as much as our society has gotten to the point of kind of downgrading, some stigma around common mental illnesses like depression and anxiety, there still is, I think, a big corner of society that sees people who experience mental illness as weak or incapable, unable to kind of operate in society. I just think that's bullshit, firstly. But I also kind of want|||所以我觉得抗抑郁药这个话题超级有趣，但也超级容易被很多人误解。不用说，录制这期节目我其实有点紧张。我认为这是一个相当脆弱的话题，尽管我们的社会已经开始逐渐消除对抑郁症和焦虑症等常见精神疾病的一些污名化，但我认为社会上仍然很大一部分人将经历精神疾病的人视为软弱或无能、无法在社会中正常生活的人。首先，我绝对觉得这是无稽之谈。但我也想借此机会
to discuss, yeah, why that's, A, not the case, but B, how medication kind of plays into that stigma narrative and why it is such an important thing to talk about if you are on antidepressants if you're considering going on antidepressants this is just my personal experience and some kind of like basic facts basic research that I've gathered to give this a bit of a evidence-based backbone but I'm definitely not a doctor and if it's something you're considering go to your GP discuss it with them, have an ongoing conversation with any mental health professionals in your life, with your family, with your friends, with your partner, if you have one. But yes, definitely do not take this as a source of all known medical advice. That's not what this is intended to be.
to discuss, yeah, why that's, A, not the case, but B, how medication kind of plays into that stigma narrative and why it is such an important thing to talk about if you are on antidepressants if you're considering going on antidepressants this is just my personal experience and some kind of like basic facts basic research that I've gathered to give this a bit of a evidence-based backbone but I'm definitely not a doctor and if it's something you're considering go to your GP discuss it with them, have an ongoing conversation with any mental health professionals in your life, with your family, with your friends, with your partner, if you have one. But yes, definitely do not take this as a source of all known medical advice. That's not what this is intended to be.|||探讨一下，第一，为什么事实并非如此；第二，药物是如何卷入这种污名化叙事的，以及为什么谈论这个话题如此重要——如果你正在服用抗抑郁药，或者正在考虑服用抗抑郁药的话。这只是我个人的经历，以及我收集的一些基本事实和基础研究，以为这期节目提供一点循证医学的支撑，但我绝对不是医生。如果你正在考虑服用，请去看你的全科医生，与他们讨论，与你生活中的任何心理健康专业人士、你的家人、你的朋友、你的伴侣（如果你有的话）保持持续的交流。但是，绝对不要把这当作所有已知医疗建议的来源。这本就不是它的目的。
Also, it's just a discussion and maybe just kind of an informational podcast on what it was like for me, what it continues to be like for me, how it impacts my life and how it has improved my life immensely. So antidepressants in our 20s. I think I've said this on many podcasts where I've talked about mental ill health and mental illness in the past, but you're most likely to develop signs of any future mental ill health in your late teens and your early 20s. So that's why I think it's super important to talk about where medication kind of falls into that journey whilst we are in in these like kind of early decades of our lives, just so we kind of set the narrative straight around what it's really like. So most people who experience depression or anxiety will go
Also, it's just a discussion and maybe just kind of an informational podcast on what it was like for me, what it continues to be like for me, how it impacts my life and how it has improved my life immensely. So antidepressants in our 20s. I think I've said this on many podcasts where I've talked about mental ill health and mental illness in the past, but you're most likely to develop signs of any future mental ill health in your late teens and your early 20s. So that's why I think it's super important to talk about where medication kind of falls into that journey whilst we are in in these like kind of early decades of our lives, just so we kind of set the narrative straight around what it's really like. So most people who experience depression or anxiety will go|||此外，这只是一次讨论，也许只是一档信息分享型播客，讲述对我来说这是怎样的体验、现在对它是怎样的体验、它如何影响我的生活，以及它如何极大地改善了我的生活。所以，谈谈我们20多岁时接触的抗抑郁药。我想我在过去谈论心理健康不佳和精神疾病的许多播客中都说过这一点，你在青少年晚期和20岁出头时，最容易出现未来精神健康问题的迹象。这就是为什么我认为在我们的生活还处于这头几十年的阶段时，讨论药物在这个旅程中处于什么位置超级重要，这样我们就能厘清关于真实情况的叙事。因此，大多数经历过抑郁或焦虑的人都会
on some form of medication probably in this decade, probably before the age of 30, in their early 20s, some people even in their late teens, which is a little bit controversial, but it happens nonetheless. So having a good grasp of what that actually means for your brain, what you can expect, is something that I have been pondering for a while and thought was really important to talk about them. And like I've said, stigma around it is still so prevalent. I don't need to explain that to people. I think we see it everywhere all the time. People thinking that those with mental illness are somehow unable to hold jobs and able to take care of their face. families, unable to function, and I just don't think that's the case, especially when medication
on some form of medication probably in this decade, probably before the age of 30, in their early 20s, some people even in their late teens, which is a little bit controversial, but it happens nonetheless. So having a good grasp of what that actually means for your brain, what you can expect, is something that I have been pondering for a while and thought was really important to talk about them. And like I've said, stigma around it is still so prevalent. I don't need to explain that to people. I think we see it everywhere all the time. People thinking that those with mental illness are somehow unable to hold jobs and able to take care of their face. families, unable to function, and I just don't think that's the case, especially when medication|||在这个十年里、可能在30岁之前、在20岁出头时开始服用某种形式的药物，有些人甚至在青少年晚期就开始了，这虽然有点争议，但确实发生了。因此，对这对你的大脑究竟意味着什么、你能期待什么有一个很好的了解，是我一直在思考的问题，并认为谈论这些非常重要。正如我所说，围绕它的污名化仍然非常普遍。我不需要向大家解释这一点。我想我们随时随地都能看到这种现象：人们认为患有精神疾病的人不知为何无法保住工作、无法照顾好自己。家庭，无法正常运转，而我根本不认为事实如此，尤其是当药物
is something that you take and something that is part of your kind of mental health journey. Additionally, I did some searching. One in seven adult Australians are on some form of antidepressant. It is one of the 10 most prescribed drugs in Australia. So whatever stigma there may be, whatever stigma that you may hold, I would just ask you to challenge that a little bit and think about the fact that there is probably someone in your life who has been on this medication, who may need to go on this medication. Maybe you will have to one day and there's really no shame in that. It's like taking a panadol when you've got a headache.
is something that you take and something that is part of your kind of mental health journey. Additionally, I did some searching. One in seven adult Australians are on some form of antidepressant. It is one of the 10 most prescribed drugs in Australia. So whatever stigma there may be, whatever stigma that you may hold, I would just ask you to challenge that a little bit and think about the fact that there is probably someone in your life who has been on this medication, who may need to go on this medication. Maybe you will have to one day and there's really no shame in that. It's like taking a panadol when you've got a headache.|||成为你服用并构成你心理健康旅程一部分的东西时。此外，我做了一些搜索。每七个成年澳大利亚人中就有一个在服用某种抗抑郁药。它是澳大利亚处方量前十的药物之一。所以，无论存在什么样的污名化，无论你内心可能有什么样的污名化，我只想请你稍微挑战一下这种观念，想想这样一个事实：你的生活中可能就有人一直在服用这种药物，或者可能需要服用这种药物。也许有一天你也不得不服用，这真的没什么好羞耻的。这就好比头痛时吃一片必理痛。
I think when we start seeing mental ill health as ill health that would be treated like we would treat a physical injury, a broken. bone, migraine, you know, COVID, something like that. And we're looking for treatment options and seeing those as part of that journey. That's when we really start to actually respect mental ill health is just as valid as physical ill health. Treatment and medication is a big part of that. So that's what we're going to be kind of discussing today. And yeah, I hope that it's enjoyable when you gain something from this.
I think when we start seeing mental ill health as ill health that would be treated like we would treat a physical injury, a broken. bone, migraine, you know, COVID, something like that. And we're looking for treatment options and seeing those as part of that journey. That's when we really start to actually respect mental ill health is just as valid as physical ill health. Treatment and medication is a big part of that. So that's what we're going to be kind of discussing today. And yeah, I hope that it's enjoyable when you gain something from this.|||我认为，当我们开始将心理健康问题视同身体损伤（如骨折、偏头痛或新冠等疾病）来对待时，当我们寻找治疗方案并将其视为康复旅程的一部分时，我们才真正开始尊重心理健康问题，承认它与身体健康问题同样重要。治疗和药物是其中非常重要的一部分。这就是我们今天要讨论的内容。是的，我希望这个过程是愉快的，并且你能从中有所收获。
So perhaps the first thing we kind of need to wrap our heads around when we're talking about antidepressants is what exactly are they um there is this great big myth i think a lot of people panned to that they're kind of like a happy pill um you know you take your antidepressants and suddenly like the world's more colorful everything feels better um and it's an easy way out of for those who are experiencing depression or anxiety that is um absolutely not the case at least it hasn't been my case in um my experience with them antidepressants were on the basis that there is a chemical imbalance in your brain that is causing you to experience happiness less frequently. It's causing you to experience more depressive episodes and
So perhaps the first thing we kind of need to wrap our heads around when we're talking about antidepressants is what exactly are they um there is this great big myth i think a lot of people panned to that they're kind of like a happy pill um you know you take your antidepressants and suddenly like the world's more colorful everything feels better um and it's an easy way out of for those who are experiencing depression or anxiety that is um absolutely not the case at least it hasn't been my case in um my experience with them antidepressants were on the basis that there is a chemical imbalance in your brain that is causing you to experience happiness less frequently. It's causing you to experience more depressive episodes and|||所以，当我们谈论抗抑郁药时，我们首先需要弄清楚的一点可能是：它们到底是什么？嗯，我认为有一个流传很广的巨大迷思，很多人都对此笃信不疑，那就是它们有点像“快乐丸”——你知道的，吃了抗抑郁药，突然之间世界就变得更加绚丽多彩，一切感觉都变好了，嗯，对于那些经历抑郁或焦虑的人来说，这是一种轻松的解脱方式——事实、嗯、绝对不是这样的，至少在我的经历中不是这样的。在我与它们的接触中，抗抑郁药的原理是基于你大脑中存在化学物质失衡，这导致你体验到快乐的频率降低。它导致你经历更多的抑郁发作和
depressive periods at a greater frequency and for a longer amount of time. And with that, with many people who are experiencing that, it's also probably the case that you have higher levels of anxiety as well. Depression and anxiety as we know are often grown more. but they happen hand in hand. And in kind of, you know, after the 70s, what doctors and psychologists began to realize this isn't just, you know, because your life circumstances are crap
depressive periods at a greater frequency and for a longer amount of time. And with that, with many people who are experiencing that, it's also probably the case that you have higher levels of anxiety as well. Depression and anxiety as we know are often grown more. but they happen hand in hand. And in kind of, you know, after the 70s, what doctors and psychologists began to realize this isn't just, you know, because your life circumstances are crap|||抑郁时期，频率更高，持续时间更长。随之而来的是，对于许多经历这种情况的人来说，你很可能也伴随着更高水平的焦虑。正如我们所知，抑郁和焦虑往往会不断滋长。但它们是携手并存的。而且在70年代之后，医生和心理学家开始意识到，这不仅仅是因为你的生活状况很糟糕，
or because something traumatic has happened. Depression is not just experienced in moments of intense grief or intense suffering. It's something that people experience all the time, even when your life might be perfect, even when from the outside, everything seems to be going well, you've got food in your belly, you've got a family, you've got all the things that would fulfill you.
or because something traumatic has happened. Depression is not just experienced in moments of intense grief or intense suffering. It's something that people experience all the time, even when your life might be perfect, even when from the outside, everything seems to be going well, you've got food in your belly, you've got a family, you've got all the things that would fulfill you.|||或者因为发生了什么创伤性的事情。抑郁不仅仅是在经历强烈的悲伤或巨大的痛苦时才会体验到。它是人们一直在经历的事情，哪怕你的生活可能完美无缺，哪怕从外表上看一切都顺风顺水，你肚子有吃有喝，有家庭，拥有一切能让你感到满足的事物。
There's something still quite not right. And what they identified that as being is a chemical imbalance in your brain. Mostly and most often that being deficiency in dopamine or serotonin. And it's not just that your brain isn't producing enough of these happy chemicals, as a lot of people call them. but it's that your brain is having difficulty transmitting them, processing them, and using them for the correct reasons. So that's what the most common type of antidepressants, which are called selective serotonin reuptake inhibitors, aim to kind of fix.
There's something still quite not right. And what they identified that as being is a chemical imbalance in your brain. Mostly and most often that being deficiency in dopamine or serotonin. And it's not just that your brain isn't producing enough of these happy chemicals, as a lot of people call them. but it's that your brain is having difficulty transmitting them, processing them, and using them for the correct reasons. So that's what the most common type of antidepressants, which are called selective serotonin reuptake inhibitors, aim to kind of fix.|||仍然会觉得有些地方不太对劲。而他们找出的原因就是你大脑中的化学物质失衡。绝大多数情况下，这是多巴胺或血清素的缺乏。这不仅是因为你的大脑没有产生足够的多巴胺或血清素（许多人称之为“快乐化学物质”），而是因为你的大脑在传递、处理和为了正确目的利用这些化学物质时遇到了困难。这就是最常见的抗抑郁药——被称为选择性血清素再摄取抑制剂（SSRI）——试图去解决的问题。
So selective serotonin reuptake inhibitors, we're going to call them SSRIs. You may have heard this term before, but they're the most common type of medication that someone experiencing depression or anxiety is most likely to be prescribed. So how these work is, I guess we have to go back a step. Our neurons communicate using chemical impulses, but also chemical signals as well. So what these SSRIs are trying to do, they're not so much trying to address the electrical impulses, but the chemicals that these unlock and these chemicals are things like serotonin and dopamine. So when those chemicals are released into the synapse, which is this little gap between your neurons,
So selective serotonin reuptake inhibitors, we're going to call them SSRIs. You may have heard this term before, but they're the most common type of medication that someone experiencing depression or anxiety is most likely to be prescribed. So how these work is, I guess we have to go back a step. Our neurons communicate using chemical impulses, but also chemical signals as well. So what these SSRIs are trying to do, they're not so much trying to address the electrical impulses, but the chemicals that these unlock and these chemicals are things like serotonin and dopamine. So when those chemicals are released into the synapse, which is this little gap between your neurons,|||因此，选择性血清素再摄取抑制剂，我们简称它们为 SSRI。你可能以前听过这个词，但它们是经历抑郁或焦虑的人最有可能被开具的最常见药物类型。那么这些药物是如何起作用的呢？我想我们得回溯一步。我们的神经元通过化学冲动以及化学信号进行交流。因此，这些 SSRI 试图做的事情，与其说是试图解决电冲动的问题，不如说是解决这些电冲动所释放的化学物质，而这些化学物质就是血清素和多巴胺等。因此，当这些化学物质被释放到突触中时（突触就是神经元之间的这个小间隙），
they send messages onto the next neuron to elicit a certain feeling such as happiness or to create a behavioural action. But if those chemicals are reabsorbed too quickly or they, you know, and not enough of them as released, that's when we might start to experience in the long-term episodes of depression and of intense sadness. So what these drugs aim to do is they aim to block the sending neuron from taking back serotonin that it's released. So basically what that means is once a neuron releases serotonin, the happy hormone, the happy chemical, the SSRIs stop that neuron that scent it from kind of, you know, scooping it back up again. So it means that more of that chemical becomes available within the synapse,
they send messages onto the next neuron to elicit a certain feeling such as happiness or to create a behavioural action. But if those chemicals are reabsorbed too quickly or they, you know, and not enough of them as released, that's when we might start to experience in the long-term episodes of depression and of intense sadness. So what these drugs aim to do is they aim to block the sending neuron from taking back serotonin that it's released. So basically what that means is once a neuron releases serotonin, the happy hormone, the happy chemical, the SSRIs stop that neuron that scent it from kind of, you know, scooping it back up again. So it means that more of that chemical becomes available within the synapse,|||它们会向下一个神经元发送信息，以引发某种感觉（如快乐）或产生某种行为动作。但如果这些化学物质被重新吸收得太快，或者你知道的，释放的量不够，我们就有可能在长期内开始经历抑郁和强烈的悲伤发作。因此，这些药物的目的是阻止发送神经元收回它已经释放的血清素。所以基本上这意味着，一旦一个神经元释放了血清素（快乐荷尔蒙，快乐化学物质），SSRI 就会阻止那个发送它的神经元将其“捞”回去。这意味着更多的这种化学物质能够在突触中发挥作用，
essentially meaning that it changes the chemical structure of your brain to be more receptive to serotonin, to have more serotonin and dopamine available to you, and therefore kind of change your life and change your kind of outlook on life. So what is your brain like on antidepressants? If we have this kind of chemical understanding of how they work, So like I said, there's this myth that they're happy pills, that they work kind of like ecstasy or some kind of like immediate, they provide this immediate jolt of just like pleasure and happiness and all your suffering ceases to exist. And it's just not like that. It's not a wave of joy. It's not a wave of ecstasy. What these hormones, what these, sorry, chemical kind of drugs intend to do is to push you back into equilibrium.
essentially meaning that it changes the chemical structure of your brain to be more receptive to serotonin, to have more serotonin and dopamine available to you, and therefore kind of change your life and change your kind of outlook on life. So what is your brain like on antidepressants? If we have this kind of chemical understanding of how they work, So like I said, there's this myth that they're happy pills, that they work kind of like ecstasy or some kind of like immediate, they provide this immediate jolt of just like pleasure and happiness and all your suffering ceases to exist. And it's just not like that. It's not a wave of joy. It's not a wave of ecstasy. What these hormones, what these, sorry, chemical kind of drugs intend to do is to push you back into equilibrium.|||这实质上意味着它改变了你大脑的化学结构，使其对血清素更具接受性，让你拥有更多的血清素和多巴胺，从而在某种程度上改变你的生活和人生观。那么，服用了抗抑郁药的大脑是什么样的呢？如果我们对它们的工作原理有了这种化学层面的理解，就像我说的，有一个迷思认为它们是“快乐丸”，它们的作用有点像摇头丸或者某种即时药物，能提供即时的快感和快乐冲击，让你所有的痛苦瞬间消失。但事实并非如此。这不是一阵快乐的浪潮，也不是一阵狂喜的浪潮。这些荷尔蒙，不，抱歉，这些化学类药物旨在做的是把你推回平衡状态。
They're not trying to like push you to the other side and make you deliriously happy. they want to kind of stabilize your brain so you're at a point where you can operate. So basically, the way that I describe it is if you are someone who is depressed, like I have been for a big, you know, not a big part of my life, but for some of my life, what SSRIs do is they don't shift you all the way to this like other end of the scale. They put you back in the middle. And the result of that is that you no longer feel those like, horrifying, awful black lows. But the other side of that is you no longer feel those highs as much.
They're not trying to like push you to the other side and make you deliriously happy. they want to kind of stabilize your brain so you're at a point where you can operate. So basically, the way that I describe it is if you are someone who is depressed, like I have been for a big, you know, not a big part of my life, but for some of my life, what SSRIs do is they don't shift you all the way to this like other end of the scale. They put you back in the middle. And the result of that is that you no longer feel those like, horrifying, awful black lows. But the other side of that is you no longer feel those highs as much.|||它们并不是想把你推向另一端，让你欣喜若狂。它们是想稳定你的大脑，让你处于一个能够正常运作的状态。所以基本上，我的描述方式是：如果你是一个抑郁的人——就像我在人生中很大一部分时间里（呃，不是很大一部分，但确实有一段时间）经历过的那样——SSRI 的作用并不是把你一路推向标尺的另一端。它们把你放回中间。其结果是，你不再感到那种可怕的、糟糕的黑暗低谷。但另一方面，你也无法再像以前那样强烈地感受到那些高峰。
You no longer feel that like just like pure adrenaline of joy. The kind of upside being that you no longer have to experience those lows. It kind of steadies the roller coaster. If you can imagine like a roller coaster at Luna Park or like an amusement park, you know, the first part of the roller coaster is often like really up and down, really up and down. You've got those like the fear, the excitement, the anticipation. That's your brain without antidepressants. It's just like chaotic and there's extreme lows and extreme highs. But on antidepressants, it's kind of like that end of the roller coaster. There's still a few bumps, but they're not as significant. And it allows you to relax more. You can see you're coming to the end of the ride, that fear, that adrenaline,
You no longer feel that like just like pure adrenaline of joy. The kind of upside being that you no longer have to experience those lows. It kind of steadies the roller coaster. If you can imagine like a roller coaster at Luna Park or like an amusement park, you know, the first part of the roller coaster is often like really up and down, really up and down. You've got those like the fear, the excitement, the anticipation. That's your brain without antidepressants. It's just like chaotic and there's extreme lows and extreme highs. But on antidepressants, it's kind of like that end of the roller coaster. There's still a few bumps, but they're not as significant. And it allows you to relax more. You can see you're coming to the end of the ride, that fear, that adrenaline,|||你不再感受到那种纯粹由快乐带来的肾上腺素飙升。好处在于你不再需要经历那些低谷。它有点像让过山车平稳下来。如果你能想象一下月神公园或游乐园里的过山车，你知道，过山车的前半部分通常是上下起伏非常剧烈。你会感受到恐惧、兴奋、期待。那是没有服用抗抑郁药的大脑。它就像一团混乱，有极端的低谷和极端的高峰。但在抗抑郁药的作用下，它有点像是过山车的末端。仍然有一些颠簸，但没有那么剧烈了。这能让你更加放松。你能看到你快要到达行程的终点，那种恐惧、那种肾上腺素，
kind of starts to decrease. And that's how antidepressants are intended to make you feel. So what does this kind of tell us about depression in general. So there's been so much research into SSRIs. They were quite controversial when they came, they first came out, they still are really misunderstood, but it tells us a kind of bigger story and paints a bigger picture around what the condition of depression actually is. And that is, it's a chemical imbalance in your brain. Obviously, there are external factors that can make you depressed. There are things. things that create deep suffering and deep grief. But every day, kind of run-of-the-mill depression, not that I really like to call it that,
kind of starts to decrease. And that's how antidepressants are intended to make you feel. So what does this kind of tell us about depression in general. So there's been so much research into SSRIs. They were quite controversial when they came, they first came out, they still are really misunderstood, but it tells us a kind of bigger story and paints a bigger picture around what the condition of depression actually is. And that is, it's a chemical imbalance in your brain. Obviously, there are external factors that can make you depressed. There are things. things that create deep suffering and deep grief. But every day, kind of run-of-the-mill depression, not that I really like to call it that,|||开始逐渐减弱。这就是抗抑郁药旨在让你感受到的状态。那么，这能告诉我们关于抑郁症本身的什么信息呢？关于 SSRI 的研究已经有很多了。它们刚问世时极具争议，现在也仍然被严重误解，但它向我们讲述了一个更大的故事，描绘了一幅更广阔的画卷，关于抑郁症究竟是一种什么样的状况。那就是：它是你大脑中的化学物质失衡。显然，有一些外部因素会让你抑郁。有些事情会造成深重的痛苦和深深的悲伤。但每天那种司空见惯的抑郁——虽然我其实不太喜欢这么叫它，
but the general disorder or the general illness that is depression, is chemical, it has a chemical origin in your brain. And that's why SSRIs work so well, because they stabilize that chemical imbalance. They make more serotonin available to your brain and therefore contribute to kind of not so much a more positive outlook, but to a greater sense of control, a greater sense of kind of peace and happiness in your life. So my experience on antidepressants, I don't really have a point of reference as to whether it's common, whether it is how everyone else experiences it. But I would think that it is. Of the friends that I know who are also on this kind of medication,
but the general disorder or the general illness that is depression, is chemical, it has a chemical origin in your brain. And that's why SSRIs work so well, because they stabilize that chemical imbalance. They make more serotonin available to your brain and therefore contribute to kind of not so much a more positive outlook, but to a greater sense of control, a greater sense of kind of peace and happiness in your life. So my experience on antidepressants, I don't really have a point of reference as to whether it's common, whether it is how everyone else experiences it. But I would think that it is. Of the friends that I know who are also on this kind of medication,|||但作为一种普遍障碍或普遍疾病的抑郁症，它是化学性的，它在大脑中有着化学根源。这就是为什么 SSRI 效果如此之好，因为它们稳定了这种化学失衡。它们让大脑能够利用更多的血清素，从而不仅带来了更积极的生活态度，更重要的是在你的生活中带来了更大的掌控感、更多的平静和幸福感。所以我服用抗抑郁药的经历，我真的没有参考点来判断它是否普遍，是否是其他所有人的真实体验。但我认为是的。在我所知道的也在服用这种药物的朋友中，
that I'm on, like, they all kind of have said the same thing. So for those who might not have the privilege of having friends who are going through similar things, I thought it would be maybe interesting to talk about what my experience on this medication has been, why it has helped me what it was like going on it, what it was like kind of going off for a while, and what it's kind of done for my life. So I've been on antidepressants. for two years, I continue to be on them. At this point, it is kind of normal for me to just take one once a day. And I find that, especially when I first started taking them, it helped me a lot. It really helped me at the point of my life that I was at. I think if you met me as a person in real
that I'm on, like, they all kind of have said the same thing. So for those who might not have the privilege of having friends who are going through similar things, I thought it would be maybe interesting to talk about what my experience on this medication has been, why it has helped me what it was like going on it, what it was like kind of going off for a while, and what it's kind of done for my life. So I've been on antidepressants. for two years, I continue to be on them. At this point, it is kind of normal for me to just take one once a day. And I find that, especially when I first started taking them, it helped me a lot. It really helped me at the point of my life that I was at. I think if you met me as a person in real|||和我吃的一样的那些，他们基本上都说了同样的话。所以，对于那些可能没有那么幸运拥有经历相似事情的朋友的人来说，我想聊聊我服用这种药物的经历可能会很有趣：为什么它帮助了我，刚开始吃的时候是什么感觉，停药一段时间又是什么感觉，以及它对我的生活产生了什么影响。所以我已经服用抗抑郁药两年了，现在还在继续服用。目前，每天吃一次对我来说已经成了一种常态。我发现，尤其是在我刚开始吃的时候，它帮了我大忙。在我当时的人生阶段，它真的给了我极大的帮助。我想如果你在现实生活中遇到我，
life, and for those who do know me, I don't think that you would know that I've had, you know, experiences with depression in pretty dark times. I think I come off as very happy and pretty outgoing. Maybe you can hear that in the podcast and the things that I talk about are generally pretty upbeat or interesting. They're not really about the sadness that has sometimes been in my life. But when I did decide to go on antidepressants, I went to my GP and I kind of explained everything that I'd been going through at that point. I had mental health professionals around me, which were just an amazing asset. And he explained what this drug was,
life, and for those who do know me, I don't think that you would know that I've had, you know, experiences with depression in pretty dark times. I think I come off as very happy and pretty outgoing. Maybe you can hear that in the podcast and the things that I talk about are generally pretty upbeat or interesting. They're not really about the sadness that has sometimes been in my life. But when I did decide to go on antidepressants, I went to my GP and I kind of explained everything that I'd been going through at that point. I had mental health professionals around me, which were just an amazing asset. And he explained what this drug was,|||以及对于那些真正了解我的人来说，我不认为你会知道我曾经在相当黑暗的时期有过抑郁的经历。我觉得我给人的印象非常快乐，而且相当外向。也许你从播客里也能听出来，我谈论的事情通常都相当乐观或有趣。它们并不是关于我生活中偶尔出现的悲伤。但当我决定开始服用抗抑郁药时，我去了全科医生那里，向他详细讲述了我当时经历的一切。我的身边有心理健康专业人士，这真是一笔宝贵的财富。他向我解释了这种药是什么，
what this drug that he was going to prescribe me was, what he was going to prescribe me, what it was like and why he thought it would help me. And I remember him saying to me, this is not something you take for six months. It's not something you take for a year. It's something that you take for a while. Because your brain takes time to adjust
what this drug that he was going to prescribe me was, what he was going to prescribe me, what it was like and why he thought it would help me. And I remember him saying to me, this is not something you take for six months. It's not something you take for a year. It's something that you take for a while. Because your brain takes time to adjust|||他打算给我开的是什么药，药效如何，以及他为什么认为这会对我有帮助。我记得他对我说过这样的话：这不是吃六个月的药。也不是吃一年的药。这是你需要服用一段时间的药。因为你的大脑需要时间来适应，
and there is, it's probably not particularly healthy, to go off them cold turkey. Now, this is really personal, and I was kind of hesitant to talk about it, but, you know, I think it's important. And at the end of the day, what really drew me to take and to get on antidepressants was just the sense that what I was going through, I just couldn't endure it. I was really struggling, and I don't think that's something that you need to be experiencing,
and there is, it's probably not particularly healthy, to go off them cold turkey. Now, this is really personal, and I was kind of hesitant to talk about it, but, you know, I think it's important. And at the end of the day, what really drew me to take and to get on antidepressants was just the sense that what I was going through, I just couldn't endure it. I was really struggling, and I don't think that's something that you need to be experiencing,|||而且，突然彻底停药可能并不是特别健康。好吧，这非常私人，我一开始有点犹豫要不要讲出来，但是，你知道的，我认为这很重要。归根结底，真正吸引我开始服用抗抑郁药的原因，仅仅是因为我觉得我当时正在经历的一切，我已经无法忍受了。我当时真的在苦苦挣扎，我不认为这是你必须经历的事情，
especially with all the options these days. I'd been so hesitant about going on it before when it had been suggested to me. I think because I myself was experiencing a lot of personal stigma around, what do it mean for my character? The fact that I couldn't just persevere, the fact that I couldn't just change my life and make myself happy through daily habits and through exercise and healthy eating. But the thing that I came to realize is that taking medication is a daily habit.
especially with all the options these days. I'd been so hesitant about going on it before when it had been suggested to me. I think because I myself was experiencing a lot of personal stigma around, what do it mean for my character? The fact that I couldn't just persevere, the fact that I couldn't just change my life and make myself happy through daily habits and through exercise and healthy eating. But the thing that I came to realize is that taking medication is a daily habit.|||尤其是考虑到现在有这么多的选择。以前有人建议我服用时，我一直非常犹豫。我想是因为我自己身上背负着很多个人层面的污名感，比如：这对我的人格意味着什么？这意味着我无法仅仅靠毅力坚持下去，意味着我无法通过日常习惯、锻炼和健康饮食来改变生活并让自己快乐。但我后来意识到的是：服药本身就是一个日常习惯。
It is you taking action to help your brain, to help your body to get better. So I went on them and the first experience that I really felt was just like extreme fatigue. So as my GP had explained, it takes a little bit of time to adjust to your new brain, I guess, to adjust to the fact that your brain suddenly has this new drug in its bloodstream, passing through the blood-brain-brain-brain barrier, creating chemical changes. between your neurons. And I just felt so tired, so tired and numb for the first maybe month or two that I was on
It is you taking action to help your brain, to help your body to get better. So I went on them and the first experience that I really felt was just like extreme fatigue. So as my GP had explained, it takes a little bit of time to adjust to your new brain, I guess, to adjust to the fact that your brain suddenly has this new drug in its bloodstream, passing through the blood-brain-brain-brain barrier, creating chemical changes. between your neurons. And I just felt so tired, so tired and numb for the first maybe month or two that I was on|||这是你在采取行动帮助你的大脑、帮助你的身体好转。于是我开始服药，我真正感受到的第一个体验就是极度的疲劳。正如我的全科医生所解释的那样，需要一点时间来适应你的“新大脑”，我想，也就是适应你的大脑血流中突然有了这种新药物、它穿过了血脑屏障、在你的神经元之间产生化学变化的过程。在吃药的头一两个月里，我只觉得好累好累，整个人都很麻木，
them. And I was like, these are not working. There is no point being on them. Yes, I don't feel sad, but I really don't feel anything at all. Is that really how I want to feel? I think I particularly really like to feel elated. I like to feel extreme joy. I like to experience like hegnism and like really enjoy my life.
them. And I was like, these are not working. There is no point being on them. Yes, I don't feel sad, but I really don't feel anything at all. Is that really how I want to feel? I think I particularly really like to feel elated. I like to feel extreme joy. I like to experience like hegnism and like really enjoy my life.|||我心想：这些药根本没用。继续吃下去毫无意义。没错，我不难过了，但我真的什么感觉也没有了。这真的是我想要的感觉吗？我觉得我特别喜欢那种兴高采烈的感觉。我喜欢体验极致的快乐。我喜欢体验享乐主义，真正享受我的生活。
And I was like, okay, maybe it's worth experiencing those lows knowing that I get that reward of feeling elated and ecstatic and like high on life. But like my GP said, it takes a couple months, three months to kind of really see how your brain is going to react. So I kept going and I kept putting, you know, kind of pushing through. And that fatigue went away. Those, you know, that sense of being heavy and of being numb went away. The world became clearer and it also became more manageable. Before I went on them and before I went on my particular dosage, everything in my life just felt completely out of control. Like, I didn't know what to do.
And I was like, okay, maybe it's worth experiencing those lows knowing that I get that reward of feeling elated and ecstatic and like high on life. But like my GP said, it takes a couple months, three months to kind of really see how your brain is going to react. So I kept going and I kept putting, you know, kind of pushing through. And that fatigue went away. Those, you know, that sense of being heavy and of being numb went away. The world became clearer and it also became more manageable. Before I went on them and before I went on my particular dosage, everything in my life just felt completely out of control. Like, I didn't know what to do.|||我当时想：好吧，也许为了获得那种兴高采烈、欣喜若狂、犹如人生巅峰的奖励，去经历那些低谷是值得的。但正如我的全科医生所说，需要几个月、三个月的时间才能真正看出你的大脑会有什么反应。所以我坚持了下来，你知道的，咬牙坚持了下去。那种疲劳感消失了。那种沉重感和麻木感也消失了。世界变得更加清晰，也变得更加可控了。在我开始吃药之前，在我服用特定剂量之前，我生活中的一切都感觉完全失控了。就像，我不知道该怎么办。
I couldn't force my brain to interpret situations. the way that I wanted it to. I wanted it to. And like life was just like not feeling amazing. And after three months, it may have been in combination with other lifestyle changes. Who can really say, some people say it's placebo effect, but I did start to feel a lot better. I started to feel so many improvements in how I could identify my emotions and address them. The one thing that did kind of stick around though is that experience that I've talked about a little bit earlier. Yes, I was not, you know, spending days in bed, but I also wasn't, you know, as excited by my life as I had been before, which was something that was really hard for me to give up.
I couldn't force my brain to interpret situations. the way that I wanted it to. I wanted it to. And like life was just like not feeling amazing. And after three months, it may have been in combination with other lifestyle changes. Who can really say, some people say it's placebo effect, but I did start to feel a lot better. I started to feel so many improvements in how I could identify my emotions and address them. The one thing that did kind of stick around though is that experience that I've talked about a little bit earlier. Yes, I was not, you know, spending days in bed, but I also wasn't, you know, as excited by my life as I had been before, which was something that was really hard for me to give up.|||我无法强迫我的大脑按照我想要的方式去解读各种情况。我当时真的很想。生活感觉一点也不美妙。三个月后——可能也结合了其他生活方式的改变，谁说得准呢，有些人说是安慰剂效应——但我确实开始感觉好多了。我开始感觉到，在识别和处理自己的情绪方面有了很大的改善。不过，有一点确实残留了下来，那就是我刚才稍微提到过的那种体验。是的，我不再成天躺在床上了，但我也确实不像以前那样对生活充满激情了，这一点对我来说真的很难割舍。
But over time, it did start getting better, you know, as my brain, adjusted to having this little helper and having this assistance, there started to be more of an equilibrium and a balance between those periods of like pure elation and joy and happiness. And those lows weren't as deep, one as crushing, weren't as debilitating. And I found that I could manage my life a lot more. So that's the idea, that's kind of what happened around starting. Other things that I noticed was I was always thirsty. that was just like something really weird.
But over time, it did start getting better, you know, as my brain, adjusted to having this little helper and having this assistance, there started to be more of an equilibrium and a balance between those periods of like pure elation and joy and happiness. And those lows weren't as deep, one as crushing, weren't as debilitating. And I found that I could manage my life a lot more. So that's the idea, that's kind of what happened around starting. Other things that I noticed was I was always thirsty. that was just like something really weird.|||但随着时间的推移，情况确实开始好转了，你知道的，随着我的大脑适应了这个“小帮手”和这种协助，纯粹的狂喜、快乐与幸福的时期之间开始有了更多的平衡。那些低谷不再那么深不可测，不再那么令人崩溃，也不再那么使人虚弱了。我发现自己更能掌控生活了。这就是整个思路，大致就是刚开始吃药时发生的事情。我注意到的其他事情是，我总是口渴。这真是一件很奇怪的事。
I put on weight, which I didn't really mind because I was like, fuck it, that's totally worth it. And I think that's about it. Yeah, I had a bit of insomnia to begin with as well. But I think that was just the fact that I was also really anxious. But all in all, after three months, it all just kind of started to kind of figure itself out. And since then, I've kind of been on them. And there was a point when I decided that, you know, I wanted to. to stop. I didn't want to be on these for much longer.
I put on weight, which I didn't really mind because I was like, fuck it, that's totally worth it. And I think that's about it. Yeah, I had a bit of insomnia to begin with as well. But I think that was just the fact that I was also really anxious. But all in all, after three months, it all just kind of started to kind of figure itself out. And since then, I've kind of been on them. And there was a point when I decided that, you know, I wanted to. to stop. I didn't want to be on these for much longer.|||我长胖了，但我其实并不介意，因为我想：管他呢，这完全值得。我想大概就是这些了。是的，一开始我也有点失眠。但我认为那只是因为我当时也确实非常焦虑。不过总而言之，三个月后，一切都开始慢慢步入正轨。从那以后，我基本上就一直在服药。直到有一次我决定，你知道的，我想停药了。我不想再吃这么久了。
Kind of thought about how long I'd been taking this medication, read a few books that I probably shouldn't have read about like alternative therapies, you know, do your research, I guess, if that's the thing you want to read. And if you want to think about other ways to manage depression or anxiety, if you're experiencing it, it's totally up to you. But always seek healthcare advice, I think, is the thing. And there are some like pretty serious dates. if you decide to stop taking your antidepressant, your SSRI, like cold turkey. It's like withdrawal from any other type of drug. Your brain is addicted to it.
Kind of thought about how long I'd been taking this medication, read a few books that I probably shouldn't have read about like alternative therapies, you know, do your research, I guess, if that's the thing you want to read. And if you want to think about other ways to manage depression or anxiety, if you're experiencing it, it's totally up to you. But always seek healthcare advice, I think, is the thing. And there are some like pretty serious dates. if you decide to stop taking your antidepressant, your SSRI, like cold turkey. It's like withdrawal from any other type of drug. Your brain is addicted to it.|||我盘算着自己已经吃这种药多久了，还读了一些本不该读的关于替代疗法的书——如果你想读这些，我猜你得自己做好研究。如果你想寻找其他方法来管理抑郁或焦虑（如果你正在经历的话），那完全取决于你。但我认为最重要的一点是，永远要寻求医疗保健建议。如果你决定彻底停掉你的抗抑郁药、你的 SSRI，也就是突然断药，会有一些相当严重的日子。这就像戒除其他任何类型的药物一样。你的大脑对它产生了依赖。
You are taking it regularly. Your brain is not used to operating without it. And I weren't like, I think about stopping every month. There will be days when I just don't take my antidepressant or sometimes even, you know, half a week. I think the most was a week. and at that point, after a week of not taking it, oh my God, did I start to notice? And I was told that, you know, if you were to stop cold turkey, you're probably going to experience this thing called discontinuation syndrome.
You are taking it regularly. Your brain is not used to operating without it. And I weren't like, I think about stopping every month. There will be days when I just don't take my antidepressant or sometimes even, you know, half a week. I think the most was a week. and at that point, after a week of not taking it, oh my God, did I start to notice? And I was told that, you know, if you were to stop cold turkey, you're probably going to experience this thing called discontinuation syndrome.|||你在规律服药。你的大脑已经习惯了它的存在，不习惯在没有它的情况下运转。我并不是说——我每个月都会考虑停药。总会有那么几天，我就是不吃抗抑郁药，有时甚至，你知道的，断药半周。我想最长的一次是一周。就在那个时候，断药一周后，天哪，我开始有感觉了！我被告知，你知道的，如果你突然彻底断药，你很可能会经历一种叫做“撤药综合征”的东西。
And I had a little bit of a taste of it. It was just like tingling sensations, trembling, headaches, confusion, vertigo, and it can get a lot worse. You know, people have extreme insomnia. a return of extreme anxiety, sweating, trembling, vomiting, and that confusion I was talking about. And I just remember I hadn't taken them for a week. It was not intentional. Maybe it was unconsciously, but I don't remember being like, I'm going to go off them. I just hadn't taken it. And I was riding home from the pool on my bike and I just all of a sudden got this like
And I had a little bit of a taste of it. It was just like tingling sensations, trembling, headaches, confusion, vertigo, and it can get a lot worse. You know, people have extreme insomnia. a return of extreme anxiety, sweating, trembling, vomiting, and that confusion I was talking about. And I just remember I hadn't taken them for a week. It was not intentional. Maybe it was unconsciously, but I don't remember being like, I'm going to go off them. I just hadn't taken it. And I was riding home from the pool on my bike and I just all of a sudden got this like|||我稍微体验了一下这种滋味。那感觉就像是刺痛感、颤抖、头痛、意识模糊、眩晕，而且情况可能会变得糟糕得多。你知道的，有人会出现极度失眠。极端焦虑的回归、出汗、颤抖、呕吐，以及我刚才说的意识模糊。我还记得我有一周没吃药了。这不是故意的。也许是无意识的，但我不记得自己曾想过“我要停药了”。我只是没吃而已。当时我正骑着自行车从游泳池回家，突然之间，
incredible, dizzy front of the head feeling and confusion. And I, I just, all of a sudden, I got my head started to her and I just felt awful. I felt extreme dissociation. Like I couldn't really feel my body and I was just had this pounding headache. And the next day I woke up, same feeling. Everything just felt really confusing. Everything felt a little bit out of place. My head hurt.
incredible, dizzy front of the head feeling and confusion. And I, I just, all of a sudden, I got my head started to her and I just felt awful. I felt extreme dissociation. Like I couldn't really feel my body and I was just had this pounding headache. And the next day I woke up, same feeling. Everything just felt really confusing. Everything felt a little bit out of place. My head hurt.|||我感到头部前方一阵难以置信的眩晕和意识模糊。然后，我、我突然开始头痛欲裂，感觉糟糕透了。我感到了极度的解离。就好像我无法真正感受到自己的身体，只觉得脑袋像要炸裂一样疼。第二天醒来，还是这种感觉。一切都觉得非常混乱。一切都显得有些格格不入。我头痛欲裂。
I was sweating. I couldn't sleep. And that both scared me for two. That really scared me for two reasons. firstly it scared me because I was like oh my god this is an awful feeling I don't want to feel like this again so I'm going to go back on these because if this is what life was before I was on them a it's much worse than I imagine and B I don't really want to go back but it also scared me because I had this sense of like have I permanently damaged my brain am I going to be on
I was sweating. I couldn't sleep. And that both scared me for two. That really scared me for two reasons. firstly it scared me because I was like oh my god this is an awful feeling I don't want to feel like this again so I'm going to go back on these because if this is what life was before I was on them a it's much worse than I imagine and B I don't really want to go back but it also scared me because I had this sense of like have I permanently damaged my brain am I going to be on|||我直冒冷汗，根本无法入睡。这让我感到害怕，原因有二。这真的让我害怕，出于两个原因：首先，它吓到我了，因为我在想：“天哪，这种感觉太糟糕了，我再也不想有这种感觉了，所以我要回去继续吃药，因为如果这就是我吃药前的生活，第一，它比我想象的要糟得多；第二，我真的不想回到那种状态。”但它也吓到我了，因为我产生了一种感觉：我是不是永远地损伤了自己的大脑？我是不是要在
this for the rest of my life and is my brain hooked on these things is my brain unable to operate without this assistance? And is this what it's going to be like if I ever decide that this isn't what I want to do anymore? And that was really, really terrifying. I think that was also exacerbated by the fact that withdrawing from antidepressants is like withdrawing from any drug because it's become a part of your system and a part of your biology in some senses. So, you know, ceasing to take it really quickly. you can't really trust your emotional and mental and cognitive reactions to things,
this for the rest of my life and is my brain hooked on these things is my brain unable to operate without this assistance? And is this what it's going to be like if I ever decide that this isn't what I want to do anymore? And that was really, really terrifying. I think that was also exacerbated by the fact that withdrawing from antidepressants is like withdrawing from another drug because it's become a part of your system and a part of your biology in some senses. So, you know, ceasing to take it really quickly. you can't really trust your emotional and mental and cognitive reactions to things,|||余生都依赖这种药了？我的大脑是不是对这些东西上瘾了？我的大脑是不是没有了这种协助就无法运转了？如果我有一天决定这不再是我想要的生活，情况就会变成这样吗？这真的、真的很恐怖。我想，这也因为另一个事实而加剧了：戒断抗抑郁药就像戒除其他药物一样，因为它在某种意义上已经成为了你身体系统和生物学的一部分。所以，你知道的，非常迅速地停止服药，你真的无法信任自己对事物的的情绪、精神和认知反应，
especially in those first few weeks, because your brain is adapting to a whole new way of perceiving the world, a whole new kind of chemical system and mechanization that is just really confusing and one that you probably haven't experienced for a while. So I did end up going back on them, and that's happened a few more times where I've just, you know, gone on a holiday, forgotten to bring them, had those awful symptoms, come back and been like,
especially in those first few weeks, because your brain is adapting to a whole new way of perceiving the world, a whole new kind of chemical system and mechanization that is just really confusing and one that you probably haven't experienced for a while. So I did end up going back on them, and that's happened a few more times where I've just, you know, gone on a holiday, forgotten to bring them, had those awful symptoms, come back and been like,|||尤其是在最初的几个星期里，因为你的大脑正在适应一种感知世界的全新方式、一种全新的化学系统和机制，这真的让人很困惑，而且可能是你一段时间以来从未经历过的。所以我最终还是回去继续吃药了，这种情况后来又发生了好几次，比如，你知道的，我去度假，忘了带药，出现了那些糟糕的症状，回来后就想：
yeah, I don't know what I was thinking. This is not for me. And I think that is kind of an important sidebar to make note of. If you're thinking about taking antidepressants, don't take it lightly. It's not a six-month happy, you know, happy crash course. Like, it's something that your brain and that your body will be on and hooked on for some time. And going off them is not as simple as being like, okay I'm ready to step back into the real world and experience things like, you know, as they are.
yeah, I don't know what I was thinking. This is not for me. And I think that is kind of an important sidebar to make note of. If you're thinking about taking antidepressants, don't take it lightly. It's not a six-month happy, you know, happy crash course. Like, it's something that your brain and that your body will be on and hooked on for some time. And going off them is not as simple as being like, okay I'm ready to step back into the real world and experience things like, you know, as they are.|||是的，我当时真不知道自己在想什么。这根本不适合我。我认为这是一个需要注意的重要插曲。如果你正在考虑服用抗抑郁药，切勿掉以轻心。它不是一个为期六个月的快乐速成班。它需要你的大脑和身体持续服用并依赖一段时间。停药并不是说一句“好吧，我准备好重返现实世界，按原样去体验生活了”那么简单。
It's a lot more complicated than that. So I guess in recent years, some kind of areas of the psychological and medical and mental health community have kind of been turning away from the prescription of medication, particularly drugs like SSRIs, because there is more of a focus on holistic healing and positive psychology and, you know, mind-body connection and lifestyle changes, which I'm totally a fan of. I think that that is an amazing movement and an amazing direction to kind of be pushing our ideas of mental health towards, but it doesn't really provide a full picture. And I don't think that it should put any shame on people who do continue to use medication
It's a lot more complicated than that. So I guess in recent years, some kind of areas of the psychological and medical and mental health community have kind of been turning away from the prescription of medication, particularly drugs like SSRIs, because there is more of a focus on holistic healing and positive psychology and, you know, mind-body connection and lifestyle changes, which I'm totally a fan of. I think that that is an amazing movement and an amazing direction to kind of be pushing our ideas of mental health towards, but it doesn't really provide a full picture. And I don't think that it should put any shame on people who do continue to use medication|||它要复杂得多。所以我想，近年来，心理学、医学和心理健康领域的某些板块开始逐渐减少药物处方，尤其是像 SSRI 这样的药物，因为大家更多地关注整体疗愈、积极心理学、身心连接以及生活方式的改变——我完全是这一趋势的拥趸。我认为这是一场了不起的运动，也是推动我们对心理健康的理解朝着正确方向发展的一个了不起的方向，但它并不能真正提供一幅完整的全景图。而且我认为，这不应该给那些继续使用药物的人带来任何羞耻感，
because that's the best thing for them. Also, I think it's important to realize that holistic healing and, you know, adopting healthy practices has a price to it, has an entry fee. It's pretty expensive to do Pilates and drink green juice and spend time outdoors if you have to work all the time. And if you don't have the income for it or if you have kids that you need to look after. And sometimes you just need to need. the safety net of knowing that your medication or your SSRI is kind of taking care of things for you whilst you continue to live your life and gives you time to kind of get back on your feet and
because that's the best thing for them. Also, I think it's important to realize that holistic healing and, you know, adopting healthy practices has a price to it, has an entry fee. It's pretty expensive to do Pilates and drink green juice and spend time outdoors if you have to work all the time. And if you don't have the income for it or if you have kids that you need to look after. And sometimes you just need to need. the safety net of knowing that your medication or your SSRI is kind of taking care of things for you whilst you continue to live your life and gives you time to kind of get back on your feet and|||因为这对他们来说是最好的选择。此外，我认为重要的是要认识到，整体疗愈和采取健康的习惯是有代价的、是有门槛的。如果你必须一直工作，要做普拉提、喝绿汁、花时间去户外，其实是相当昂贵的。如果你没有这笔收入，或者有孩子需要照顾。有时你真的需要那种安全网，那就是知道你的药物或 SSRI 正在为你照料一切，而你则可以继续过自己的生活，并给你时间重新振作起来，
sort out what practices you want to incorporate. So, funny story, my friends, Jalc and Julian, friends of the show, they gave me this really interesting book for my birthday nonetheless about depression. Thank you, boys. Yes, very funny. But also, very sweet and it was called lost connections and this book was something that I read when I was kind of considering whether I wanted to continue to stay on my antidepressants and it provides an alternative point of view if you're interested in it definitely go and give it a read I'm pretty sure Russell Brand has like a review on the front so that's the kind of literature you're getting into the kind of thoughts and ideas and it basically explained that no depression isn't a chemical
sort out what practices you want to incorporate. So, funny story, my friends, Jalc and Julian, friends of the show, they gave me this really interesting book for my birthday nonetheless about depression. Thank you, boys. Yes, very funny. But also, very sweet and it was called lost connections and this book was something that I read when I was kind of considering whether I wanted to continue to stay on my antidepressants and it provides an alternative point of view if you're interested in it definitely go and give it a read I'm pretty sure Russell Brand has like a review on the front so that's the kind of literature you're getting into the kind of thoughts and ideas and it basically explained that no depression isn't a chemical|||弄清楚你想将哪些实践融入生活中。所以，说个好笑的事，我的朋友 Jalc 和 Julian（节目的朋友）居然送了我一本关于抑郁症的有趣书籍作为生日礼物。谢谢你们，男孩们。是的，非常搞笑。但也很贴心，这本书叫《失落的连结》（Lost Connections）。当我考虑是否要继续服用抗抑郁药时，我读了这本书。如果你感兴趣，它提供了一个截然不同的视角，绝对值得一读。我敢肯定拉塞尔·布兰德（Russell Brand）在封面上有过书评，所以这就是你将接触到的文学作品、涉及的种种思潮与理念，它基本上解释了：不，抑郁症不是一种化学
and balance, it is because of your perspective. It's because of your life circumstances. It's because of your cognitions rather than something innately chemical in your brain. And in some ways, that is entirely correct. When paired with things like cognitive behavioral therapy, any kind of medication is going to perform a lot better because any mental health problem is not one dimensional. And I think that's the thing that's important to remember at the end of the day. Taking a pill once a day, yes, it's really probably going to help you, but there is that period of time when it's not going to really, you're not really going to feel the full effects in that first three months.
and balance, it is because of your perspective. It's because of your life circumstances. It's because of your cognitions rather than something innately chemical in your brain. And in some ways, that is entirely correct. When paired with things like cognitive behavioral therapy, any kind of medication is going to perform a lot better because any mental health problem is not one dimensional. And I think that's the thing that's important to remember at the end of the day. Taking a pill once a day, yes, it's really probably going to help you, but there is that period of time when it's not going to really, you're not really going to feel the full effects in that first three months.|||失衡，而是因为你的视角。是因为你的生活状况。是因为你的认知，而不是你大脑中天生有什么化学问题。在某种程度上，这完全是正确的。当与认知行为疗法（CBT）等方法相结合时，任何药物都会表现得更好，因为任何心理健康问题都不是单维度的。我认为这是归根结底需要记住的重要一点。每天吃一次药，是的，它确实可能会帮到你，但有一个时间段，在最初的三个月里，它不会真正发挥出全部效果，你也不会真正感受到全部的药效。
But also, it is about cultivating it a healthier way of seeing the world, moving away from that kind of depressed perspective and into kind of a healthier perspective on the problems that you face, your life, your relationships, and those kind of things, so that they're more manageable just in general, but also when you decide that maybe it's time to go off your medication or when things happen that mean that you can't take it anymore. So yeah, there has been this rise in this kind of alternative way of looking at depression and looking at things like anxiety that's really taken hold. But at the end of the day, and antidepressants are still
But also, it is about cultivating it a healthier way of seeing the world, moving away from that kind of depressed perspective and into kind of a healthier perspective on the problems that you face, your life, your relationships, and those kind of things, so that they're more manageable just in general, but also when you decide that maybe it's time to go off your medication or when things happen that mean that you can't take it anymore. So yeah, there has been this rise in this kind of alternative way of looking at depression and looking at things like anxiety that's really taken hold. But at the end of the day, and antidepressants are still|||但同时，这也是为了培养一种更健康的看世界的方式，摆脱那种抑郁的视角，转向一种更健康的视角来看待你所上面临的问题、你的生活、你的人际关系等等，这样它们不仅在总体上更易于掌控，而且当你决定也许是时候停药，或者发生了一些事导致你无法再服药时，也能应对自如。所以，是的，这种看待抑郁和焦虑等问题的非主流新视角确实正在兴起并站稳脚跟。但归根结底，抗抑郁药仍然是
something that are widely prescribed, that are widely available, that are accessible. I think like my prescription costs me $5 a month, which is just like incredible. Chemist Warehouse, if you are listening, sponsor me. But I do just think it's an amazing discovery and it's amazing kind of medical technology that has allowed people like myself to kind of get back on the horse and sort out their lives and think better about the circumstances they're in and form positive relationships. So yeah, a bit of a shorter episode, a really personal episode. I ask that if you have listened to this, you have an open mind about what was discussed.
something that are widely prescribed, that are widely available, that are accessible. I think like my prescription costs me $5 a month, which is just like incredible. Chemist Warehouse, if you are listening, sponsor me. But I do just think it's an amazing discovery and it's amazing kind of medical technology that has allowed people like myself to kind of get back on the horse and sort out their lives and think better about the circumstances they're in and form positive relationships. So yeah, a bit of a shorter episode, a really personal episode. I ask that if you have listened to this, you have an open mind about what was discussed.|||一种被广泛开具处方、广泛供应且极易获取的药物。我想我的处方药费一个月只要5美元，这简直不可思议。Chemist Warehouse（药房），如果你在听的话，请赞助我。但我真的认为这是一个了不起的发现，也是一项了不起的医疗技术，它让像我这样的人能够重新振作起来，理顺生活，更好地思考自己所处的环境，并建立积极的人际关系。所以，是的，这是一期较短的节目，一期非常个人化的节目。我请求，如果你听完了这期节目，请以开放的心态看待所讨论的内容。
And if you're considering adding medication into your mental health journey, definitely talk about it. Do your research. Think it through. It has its amazing benefits. It's made me a better person. It's made me a more reliable. reliable person. It's made me a happier person, but there are also downsides like discontinuation
And if you're considering adding medication into your mental health journey, definitely talk about it. Do your research. Think it through. It has its amazing benefits. It's made me a better person. It's made me a more reliable. reliable person. It's made me a happier person, but there are also downsides like discontinuation|||如果你正在考虑将药物加入到你的心理健康旅程中，一定要多交流。做点研究。仔细考虑清楚。它有惊人的好处。它让我成为了一个更好的人。它让我成为了一个更可靠的人。它让我成为了一个更快乐的人，但它也有缺点，比如撤药
syndrome, like not being on that roller coaster. And if the roller coaster is something that you enjoy and something that you can tolerate, maybe think it through before going on something that, let's be quite honest, you know, changes the structure and changes the chemical foundations of your brain. And if that, you kind of have to think about if it's worth it for you. And for me, it was. So yeah, thank you for listening with open ears and no judgment. And just for listening in general, the podcast is about to reach its one year milestone. And this is by far the most personal episode I've done. So I think in many ways my own journey with my mental health and my well-being has grown with the podcast. And has the podcast that definitely made me think about
syndrome, like not being on that roller coaster. And if the roller coaster is something that you enjoy and something that you can tolerate, maybe think it through before going on something that, let's be quite honest, you know, changes the structure and changes the chemical foundations of your brain. And if that, you kind of have to think about if it's worth it for you. And for me, it was. So yeah, thank you for listening with open ears and no judgment. And just for listening in general, the podcast is about to reach its one year milestone. And this is by far the most personal episode I've done. So I think in many ways my own journey with my mental health and my well-being has grown with the podcast. And has the podcast that definitely made me think about|||综合征，比如不再坐那种过山车。如果过山车是你喜欢且能忍受的东西，那么在决定服用某种（说实话大家都知道会改变大脑结构和化学基础的）药物之前，或许应该三思而后行。你不得不思考这对你来说是否值得。对我而言，确实值得。所以，谢谢大家以开放、不带偏见的心态聆听。感谢大家一直以来的收听，这个播客即将迎来一周年的里程碑。这也是我迄今为止做过最个人化的一期节目。所以我觉得在很多方面，我个人的心理健康和幸福感之旅是与这个播客共同成长的。正是这个播客，绝对让我开始思考
these choices and made me think about my health a lot more. So, yeah, Yeah, it's just been a really positive influence. So thank you for listening. And if you enjoyed, maybe subscribe. Leave us a raining if you'd like. And follow the podcast on Instagram, That Psychology Podcasts. And we'll be back next week with a less depressing episode. But until then, thank you again.
这些选择让我对自己的健康有了更多的思考。所以，是的，它确实是一个非常积极的影响。谢谢你们的收听。如果你喜欢，也许可以订阅我们。如果你愿意的话，给我们留个评分。并在Instagram上关注这个播客，账号是That Psychology Podcasts。我们下周会带着一期不那么压抑的节目回来。但在此之前，再次感谢大家。
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast,
嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯（Kear Games）主持的《吸取教训》（Learn the Hardway）。这个空间关注黑人男性的经历，进行在其他任何地方都觉得不太安全但却坦诚的对话，而你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持牌专业人士进行这些对话。有多少男人穿着一套铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力并不意味着你就非得这样做。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《吸取教训》。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客中，
2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the IHeart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
2%。我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中关于心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。当一群女性发现她们约会的竟然都是同一个惯犯骗子时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女性朋友们。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《The Girlfriends: Trust Me, Babe》。这是一个iHeart播客。保证真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。